la gauche française j
une malédiction qui lui est propre c'est
qu'elle est beaucoup plus clairement que
les gauches nationale de tous les autres
pays d'europe
née d'un mariage intellectuelle déjà
comme une issue et du marxisme
dans les deux cas il s'agit d'un proche
politique central à peu près pas
économique symbolique et qui rappelle
qu' il n'y a pas lieu d'améliorer
capitaliste puisque c'est central et de
leur place pourquoi tout cela parce que
dans la naissance de la gauche française
tout aujourd'hui siècle avant il y avait
une longue bataille entre les marxistes
que les autres et là le cas de la france
été marquée par la personnalité qui a
pris la direction des opérations
politiques qui s'appelait jules guesde
et qui se voulait un marxiste pur et dur
et pour qu'ils amélioraient le
capitalisme
le faire marcher un peu mieux n'était
pas le problème on en est là le résultat
est que depuis un siècle
chaque fois que la gauche arrivait pas
au pouvoir elle raté son coup donc vous
avez un refus d'intellectuels de la
gauche française d'accepter l'économie
de marché ou faux d'accepter ce que
d'autres vont appeler après un fort
bliss ce sera d'ailleurs au rayon il a
les aspirations révolutionnaires et cet
aspire à monsieur c'est d'ailleurs quand
les conditions n'y sont pas parce que
dix ans 19h36 ni aux 45 dit surtout
encadrera ya pas de conditions je n'ai
rien entendu se traduit sous la forme
d'une exigence l'électorat de la gauche
et notamment de sa partie syndicale
mais sa partie syndicale est tout petit
si elle avait été plus forte et l'aurait
peut-être préserver un peu les erreurs
parce que les syndicalistes ils eurent
général il sait ce que c'est que les
entreprises et comment ça marche mais
cosy vision faiblesse d'effectifs les
syndicats français déjà très faibles et
nos partis politiques aussi dans ces
conditions le programme de gauche est en
général une liste de symboles politiques
touchant le social la durée des congés
la paye la hiérarchie dans la paye les
conditions d'assurance sociale etc a
posé par la politique et sort jamais de
négociations c'est une très très longue
histoire très tragique la france dans
est toujours par biz et nous continuons
à peu de leur show quotidien nous
continuerons à avoir une gauche qui
naviguent dans l'incompétence le valeur
français il est là il est dans l'absence
de prise de conscience économique
l'absence d'acceptation du marché
il y à un angle à des premiers grands
sondages mendigot depuis que la chine
laisse faire chez elle la russie aussi
portait justement sur l'économie de
marché est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre l'économie de marché 85% druss
80% chinois sur pour l'économie de
marché 90% d'africains s'il vous plaît
naturellement 95,69 l'extraordinaire
bizarrerie qui est en même temps une
malédiction
autre caractéristique française c'est le
dernier des pays d'europe où l'on
n'apprend pas l'économie il ya l'école
ni au collège et au lycée
on n'apprend pas comment voulez vous que
dans un appareil environnement avec des
syndicats si faible en plus la structure
d'un syndicat maintenant c'est qu'elles
seront prêtes à cuire privé et qu'ils
restent puissantes dans le secteur
public et le secteur public on négocie
pas de l'économie on regarde pas les
grands équilibres au monde il y avait
que le vice de budget qui fait ce qu'il
peut dans ces grands équilibres à lui
tout ça est terrifiant mais tout ça
profondément culturel alors si dans
cette atmosphère là qu'au bout de 15 ans
du gaullisme
le déblocage de la situation politique
de ses 15 ans gaulliste se fait par
initiative communiste celle du programme
commun de la gauche et ce programme
commun de la gauche ça veut que voir une
sordide ailleurs l'ivoirité encore pas
kiffer a c'est un rappel du conseil
national de la résistance et le
programme du conseil national de la
résistance
j'ai eu après chassés de l'édition ne
comportent les maudits de négociations
ni de contrats dite convention ni rien
de tel déjà dans le programme du sud
quant au programme commun de la gauche
c'est la description acide italien
souffre lui d'une protection sociale
généralisée dans un système à
attribution forte c'est à dire un peu
dangereux le brave commun de la gauche
par dior prévoyait une hausse du smic
des dosettes 2% ce qui pour n'importe
quelle tête économies qui étaient
excessifs sur le plan possibilité de le
faire
et puis surtout privé est une
augmentation extrêmement important de
toutes les prestations sociales
notamment à le placer au logement
allocations familiales etc
voilà ce que ce fût que le programme
commun de gouvernement qui a eu une
formidable vertus mobilisatrices puisque
c'était la première fois depuis 50 ans
qui avait tiré une validité de la gauche
autour d'un programme
incroyablement ambitieux sans logique
interne et/ou des mots comme monnaies ou
inflation en paraissait d'heure ça
sentait vraiment l'amaigrissement est le
moyen principal c'était de maîtriser les
moyens de production des changes
d'où l'idée de nationaliser la totalité
du fisc bourgoin f et un gros tiers une
petite moitié de l'industrie française
lourde
tout ça a été très dangereux le drame
c'est que la classe intellectuelle
française s'est pas rendu compte il n'y
avait pas de connaissance économique
suffisante
tout ça a soulevé un enthousiasme autour
du thème de l'unité autour de l'idée que
la victoire devenait possible la lite
est d'ailleurs sans vraie lecture et
puis les quelques personnes qui avaient
mis le nez dans l'économie
tu es fort inquiet c'était mon cas et on
se demandait ce qui pourrait se passer
françois mitterrand pour assurer la
convergence électorale avait décidé d'y
rester en gros fidèle et il avait fait
une espèce de réécriture par la phase du
programme commun qui s'appelle les 110
propositions du candidat aux français
dans les 110 propositions il y avait cet
énorme paquet nationalisation ça
derrière qu'il soit dit comment les
faire si bien que je vais avoir à mener
une bataille au tout début du
gouvernement sur le cob enfers puis
s'était pas de cris et mais c'était très
impliqué le temps puisque en plus la
totalité du système bancaire des 10
passes et alors c'est pas un mystère on
le sait mais deux rapports personnels
entre france et 8 mois mais elle était
très mauvais mais je voudrais oublier
pourquoi ça remonte à la guerre
d'algérie site à proposer le jerry que
j'ai osé écrire qu'il était tenace à st
sipa des mots qu'il faut plaisir donc
tout ça crée une distance une méfiance
totale donc j'étais pas dans la bonne
mouvance et nous avons eu plusieurs
conversations notamment une assez longue
où j'essaie de convaincre que le
programme commun et l'idée de faire une
décoction en gardant ses tâches et les
yeux extrême était dangereux comme tout
malade doit pas possible par excéder
centralisme étatique et par excès de
dépenses et j'entreprends sans suite et
en saveurs c'est une conversation longue
plus d'une heure chez lui rue de bière
et il sait que je suis malheureux et
surtout très hostile et il me dit
souriant vous y croyez vraiment vous à
tout ça alors ma réponse et c'est le
premier secrétaire
c'est pas une affaire de croyance il ya
des données il des
statistiques il ya des chiffres il ya
des éléments de réflexion scientifique
j'ai partie de ce qu'ils autres peu
étudié croyant c'est trop je suis
absolument convaincu tout ça est
extrêmement dangereux et assurent là il
prend un tour un peu plus ferme un peu
plus dominateur et m'a dit écoutez
peut-être avez-vous enfin vous pensez
zorro maison mais je me trouve avoir
déjà derrière on a une assez longue
hier j'ai été 11 fois ministre jamais de
l'écologie qui n'est pas mon domaine
mais j'ai assisté entre les autres unis
à d'innombrables bataille économique et
cette phrase extraordinaire innombrables
thalidomide quelques saisons passées
d'investissement peu taux d'inflation
passé ceci parce que cela des
corrections et veut dit il j'ai observé
que la totalité de ces contrats verts
suisses toujours tout de la même manière
par une augmentation des taxes sur le
tabac les allumettes
alors je n'ai pas mis mon chapeau pour
dire au revoir
enfin je suis quand même parti désespéré
j'avais compris que son instrument
d'observation ne lui permettait pas mais
pas tout détailler entre le genre
d'impôts que leur faisait l'envié les
proportions lesquels elle faisait varier
et ni non plus surtout dans à leur
relation avec l'effet général de
l'écologie chômage et de croissance
rien donc je savais que qu'il n'offrait
qu'à sa tête et qu'il ne croit en rien
l'économie n'est qu'un suivent
il faut lui donner des ordres il faut
commander sommes arrivés au pouvoir dans
un enthousiasme considérable que nous
étions une demi douzaine d'individus sur
quelques millions pour partager mes jeux
parti de ceux le soir de la victoire ma
femme pleure j'étais assez économistes
pour avoir beaucoup parlé de tout ça
amusant enfin nous savions en tout cas
j'étais totalement convaincu que tout ça
nous une monnaie une catastrophe
économique épouvantable et je craignais
notamment l'augmentation dépense
publique pendant la cérémonie
d'investiture du président de la
république
j'interpelle mon ami pierre mauroy en
croissant contre un pilier un peu à
l'écart de la salle en lui disant on
sait pas où on va on est complètement
fou cette ses 110 propositions sont vont
provoquer un drame est que l'équipe le
mental
pierre françois mitterrand et elie
portes ouvertes demain matin dans 48
heures tout sera de notre faute de 48
heures
mais son responsable d' absolument tout
il a 48 heures pour prendre les
décisions précaution qui est une grande
évaluation
bon là me regarderait vague dit que si
sûr etc etc
il faut savoir que dans sa culture d'
homme généreux et de vraies politiques
droite est assise inconsciente tout ça
parce qu'il a un corps est toujours
pensé que l'obéissance de tous ceux qui
manient de la technique que cette équipe
soit financier ou préfectorales finirait
par ramener les cogneurs bon sens et
ramener les décideurs dans mon sens
situé la pensée de la gauche qui veut
incarner l'alternance ça n'a jamais
marché comme ça nulle part mais il est
dans cette pensée jeudi que pierre
défiance existant fin il ya des mesures
on sait quantifier qui s'est
complètement terrifiant nous sommes
cioni absolument folle c'est hyper
dangereux et puis tu vas voir tous nos
voisins à commencer par l'allemagne 0
reesei et se méfier de nous et ça va
casser le système monétaire européenne
très probablement alors il est dubitatif
fut impressionné et me dit bon écoute
tu es vraiment quand je vais en parler à
mitterrand et je n'entends plus parler
de rien pendant deux ou trois jours le
gouvernement et nommé le surlendemain je
pense au moment de la première réunion
du gouvernement
je me permets de nouveaux d'abord dé
pierre roy comme j'avais combattu cette
doctrine publiquement je sentais le
soufre j'étais sa discipline et un
ministre d'autant se méfiait et qui fort
loi d'être porte pas de quoi que ce soit
dans cette affaire tout de même j'avais
bien bourrin de nouveau et je lui dis
alors on dit vrai ou pas les réponses
8h a décidé on dévalue pas en période
électorale
la bestialité majeur pourquoi père
électorale parce qu'on dise il est levé
l'assemblée donc on entrait en campagne
électorale
donc dès le début nous entrons dans
l'inconscience économique l'irréalisme
le plus total et sans se rendre compte
alors le parti socialiste est en train
de changer beaucoup parce que il ya
beaucoup plus de gens qui furent de
l'écologie parmi ceux qui ont fait des
études approfondies
mais la banalise ne prend pas sur la
substance des sections les présidents de
bureaux de vote les présidents de comité
de soutien du candidat les êtres livrés
d'afficher les colleurs d'affichés pense
toujours que l'économie obéissent aux
ordres du politique et des fondeurs sont
là qu'est ce que c'est que ce réflexe
des fondeurs c'est de l'exigence d'une
signature politique au sens venant de la
seule politique du parlement ou du
gouvernement visait politique derrière
un progrès social décidées et financé de
manière économique mais décidé pour des
raisons économiques sans négociation
valois
toujours la loi j'avais le contrat
françois hollande a dit à bout de ce
genre dans la tête
mais oui vous l'attendiez pour cela ça
fait longtemps que okla d'y associer
issa comment ce niveau laisse pas de
come plus de risques vols étaient
excessifs c'est vrai mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il s'est rendu capable
d'inventer une conteuse stratégique
social-démocrate et offensives aussi ça
qui manque
et ça c'est pas non plus dans la tête de
françois hollande
j'abrège d une vraie majorité au parti
socialiste parce que j'ai cassé trop de
tabous il fallait pour ça
car s'il s'avoue et faire accepter le
retour vers les collines du marché voilà
le malheur de bourbes aubry et ben vi et
le combat contre ce malheur là et je me
reproche de n'avoir pas été assez
pédagogue qu'est ce que j'ai pu